hey guys so i wanted to share this video
with you i got a chance to vlog with
james cameron yeah james cameron of
avatar terminator titanic and he has a
new movie coming out this weekend called
sanctum and of course it's in 3d now
before i did the vlog we did this
awesome live webcast where james was
actually in a tank in the aquarium of
the pacific in long beach this aquarium
right there
and i was doing a live interview like
literally i was interviewing him while
he was in the tank hey justine how you
doing i'm good how are you i'm having a
great time i'm under water it's where i
love to be
why are you in there actually because
i'm pretty sure i'm sure most people
want to know well i always hang out here
with my fish friends at the aquarium the
pacific no we're we're doing obviously a
promotion for my new film sanctum which
i executive produced post a link in the
description if you want to watch that
hope you enjoy the video my vlog style
interview leave a comment below in the
comment section of what your favorite
james cameron movie is hello internet
friends i'm here with jim cameron okay
so you've got a new movie coming out can
you tell me a little bit about this and
it's in 3d correct that's right it's a
three well i'd shoot everything in 3d
i'd shoot my kids birthday parties in 3d
um
yeah it's called sanctum
uh it's a uh uh survival thriller takes
place in in a cave in a big unexplored
cave system in papua new guinea a bunch
of people get trapped underground and
it's there's no monster there's no kind
of you know it's not a horror film or
anything supernatural it's just a good
old-fashioned survival thriller about a
a group of people and how they either
work together or they work against each
other it's about heroism and cowardice
and
group bonds and all that sort of thing
it's so cool now you i know you're a big
fan of 3d have you played any 3d video
games oh yeah yeah i mean i mean 3d
video games are going to be the next
huge thing in gaming i think now that
the sets are available have you played
call of duty in 3d no no but i hear it's
i hear it's good
call of duty fan yeah it's intense it's
like literally like you are inside of
this game exactly hello that's what 3d
is all about it just puts you in and now
that you've got the the sort of 60-inch
monitor you just sit about two feet in
front of it and it's like it's like
playing interactive imax oh it's unreal
and you were talking about shooting your
kids in 3d now there's so many little
consumer 3d cameras now how do you think
that's going to kind of change
everything i think it is going to change
everything it's going to be cell phone
cameras will be in 3d everything's going
to be in 3d all social networking and
facebook everything will be tweeting
we're going to be tweeting
i don't know how we tweet in 3d but uh
we'll figure it out yes i mean but
you're on twitter now you're doing the
twitter thing like how did that all come
about well it came about because of
sanctum and i said okay let's let's do
this this promotion and it was supposed
to be like a limited just for one week
i'll go and tweet and it turned out to
actually be a lot of fun and i love the
the instant feedback you get from people
a lot of by the way inappropriate
comments well that's that's the nature
of being anonymous online yeah exactly
you gotta take the think the good with
the bad as they say but no always great
and it's great to get the feedback and
it's also great when people you know
retweet you see how the word spreads and
it links to other other parts of the
community it's really cool so we just
did an interview underwater right over
there yeah right right there right there
i was there you see the 400 pound black
sea bass swimming around he's my buddy
so crazy so how was that doing that
interview i mean was it different like
could you hear me okay i mean i could
hear you perfect because i wasn't under
water yeah no i could see you fine
through the through the window i could i
could hear you fine next time we get you
in the helmet as well oh my gosh i don't
i can't even swim but i would so do it
it's kind of bad on the hair in case
yeah you wind up with like like dive
hood hair when you come out what do you
think of my uh low-tech uh
vlogging camera here that's what's great
about it is for like for pennies you're
reaching an enormous audience and it's
really just the your charisma your
personality and
what do you think about the whole
youtube thing i mean it's making like
these people who i mean i i you know i
hung out with a bunch of youtube
filmmakers the other night we had dinner
together and they they told me they
they're putting up you know stuff every
week uh for like a few hundred dollars
guys i need to take some lessons from
you how to work
inexpensively because that's the part
i'm not good at that would be an amazing
video we give you some lessons on how to
work on a youtube budget right exactly
yeah okay i could probably do about a
second and a half yeah so what's this
that i hear that you guys hooked up some
people to ekgs and made them watch the
film is this true well that's how i
think i think life is a science
experiment so we had been hearing from
everybody that when you watch sanctum
you know you're so tense you feel like
you can't breathe it seemed like we were
having this physiological reaction on
people who said all right let's wire
some people up so we we put some
subjects on ekg
uh leads
and recorded the data as they watched
the movie and people had never seen it
before right and what we found is that
their heart rates were spiking up to
like 94 beats a minute which puts you
right in the fight or flight response
level that means that they were they
were actually feeling that tension i
just want to know what's really true
it's crazy well i promise that when i go
and see it i'm going to wear a heart
rate monitor and i'll i'll send you the
data okay i want i definitely want your
data and you can tell me what you know
what your peak rate was i'll tweet it to
you okay all right awesome thank you
that's so crazy you guys got to see this
man i'm so excited